Joe and the earth is seen as like an egg
yolk to give the propulsion power for
this new thing that's gonna be born and
whether you believe that or not just
like when the new thing the artificial
intelligence beyond that it's the origin
of artificial intelligence and a whole
synthesis of new life-forms and so
that's the big giant race when he'll on
must came in and told you this he goes
these billionaire functions and he has a
conscience so he's freaked out and they
go these billionaire functions I don't
just know this I've talked to people and
I was in Wired magazine 27 years ago why
the future doesn't eat us bill joy a
billionaire co-owner Sun Microsystems he
goes to a billionaire meeting with 200
guys and the consensus was weird I know
people play video games and party all
day we're gonna set up a world
government we're gonna slowly titrate
the dose and poison the public dumb I'm
down put electromagnetic radiation out
with 5g the scrambles their DNA lowers
their IQ we're gonna cause mass mental
illness and a controlled societal
collapse that will then be organized and
controlled in the mop-up crew by robots
controlled by the globalist programmers
who believe with the offworld entities
they're in communication with that
they're going to be given the operation
to upload and be in that larger kind of
Borg cube system okay they sell the
country up you gotta hit the brakes
all right everyone that was a really
important statement that Alex Jones said
on Joe Rogan and that was a really
powerful synthesis of kind of the
current state of human affairs and I
want to jump into a bunch of notes that
I have on what was actually synthesized
and disseminated so let's just jump
right into it so first big point the
Alex Jones said was that we are a nest a
yoke here we are life has evolved on
this rock and we find ourselves as
stewards of this rock now where do we go
next this is a yoke it's about to spring
forth and evolve into something what is
that gonna be have we actually realized
how divine this is that we find
ourselves now in control as stewards of
this rock - have we unlocked our full
divine potential he uses the words
breakaway civilization these are two
really important words we speak a lot
about bifurcation and about socio
economics
status about what artificial
intelligence and robotics biotech neuro
tech are all enabling us to do on this
show and we're gonna go straight to the
next point here okay
the global ruling elite vers populism
this is something that Alex Jones has
now continued to popularize and there's
been more and more leading figures
popularizing this thought experiment
that there has been and most likely will
be for as long as foreseeable future
goes that there is at the top of the
socio-economic hierarchy of power
dynamics of competence dynamics there is
a global ruling elite and there is a
populism base that's now grown to about
eight billion people on this rock and
the question is are we actually
harmonizing the ruling elite with the
populist perspective are we actually
bringing people together also hidden
parasites in tech this is so interesting
how many times have we used social media
and thought these algorithms are
manipulating me these notifications are
hooking me in and keeping me in there
longer than I want to be in there that
is that a lot of these little parasitic
ways of us having our attention and our
life force sucked out of us what's
actually happening with the 5g
infrastructure that's going into place
does that actually have potential to do
us significant harm to our DNA to our
biology are we are we actually doing
longitudinal tests on this should we be
figuring this out how can we figure this
out BCI's brain computer interfaces and
that is a whole new way of mind-control
to be to happen it's also a whole new
way for us to potentially connect to all
of the knowledge that exists so there's
so many upsides and there's so many
potential downsides vaccines or vaccines
are they 100% safe are they 100% not
coming with anything else added to them
is there's something else added to
vaccines that is causing potential harm
to people how can we dig into that and
investigate into that organ trafficking
the trafficking of human bodies the
trafficking of infants the trafficking
that is going on that is hidden that we
don't actually see how important is it
for us to highlight this and talk about
because this is actually stripping away
people's lives moving on Censorship this
is so crucial Alex Jones was censored
from platforms we see more and more
people being censored from platforms
without a judge without a jury just
being censored but these platforms are
crucial for the dissemination of ideas
and so if that is in the power of just a
couple global ruling elite to be able to
cut the free speech off of individuals
that are disseminating their ideas that
is a major major issue and what is going
on with this total surveillance control
grid that's going on right now in China
we see the evolution of things like
sesame credit their social credit system
we see things like applying artificial
intelligence and computer vision and
machine learning to facial recognition
so we can monitor people on the streets
even further and how is China and these
massive Chinese conglomerates working
with the United States and the tech
conglomerates here in the governments
here how do we figure this information
out
all right human-animal hybrids what is
the global ruling elite and what tests
are going on with the human-animal
hybrids we see more and more instances
of chimeras more and more instances of
potential genetic modifications that are
going on to make potentially it easier
to enslave these hybrids and put them to
work for us the socio-economic
bifurcation that we were talking about
the way that this is illustrated out is
through a process of siphoning resources
from the original civilization in this
egg-yolk building a brand new
civilization outside or nearby the egg
yolk and then pinning the original
civilization against each other to wipe
out that 8 billion or so and let
potentially just a couple million or
whatever the number may be in that
bifurcation build a brand new
civilization and this will be augmented
because this will be easier for them to
do will be an Augmented process for them
due to things like artificial
intelligence and robotics the brain
computer and faces bio neuro tech things
like taking the Boston Dynamics robot
that can already do a backflip all you
got to do is throw an ak-47 on that
stellar computer vision and machine
learning algorithms for it to be able to
detect the people that are causing some
sort of harm against the global ruling
elite and they will take out the
populous population that way I think
this is extremely extremely
next is the transhuman endgame that was
pointed out that there is this process
of wanting to transcend these biological
vehicles and potentially make that not
available to everyone not available to
the eight billion people not even give
people the option to stay biological to
leave the earth the way it is in many
ways we need to have a deeper global
conversation about enabling people if
they want to be trans few minutes other
people haven't even done the and I
haven't either the full self work the
full ethical divine connection to what
this existence even is let alone trans
become trans human without even figuring
out us individually and us collectively
in the first place so it seems to be a
big push for pro human Pro freewill
versus anti human anti freewill and
that's very important ok
the last last couple things are
multidimensionality and this playground
called Earth so there are potentially
other forces that are at play through us
and that was discussed so many times on
the episode that there is this very
strange chemical doorway that occurs
whether it be through dreams whether it
be through psychedelics through
meditation where we experience some sort
of past 3-dimensional connection to
whatever that essence is in that those
essences are so fascinating to tap into
and what are they doing through us how
is this how is this occurring what is a
potential God what is a potential devil
how are they at play on this on this
earth how many a different out exterior
forces are at play on playground earth
ok the deal is done there is a ticket to
immortality that is being given out
given out more and more people are being
given this there rushing rushing for
immortality rushing to digitize rushing
to be 25 years old forever rushing to be
communicative rushing to go to go
interstellar to go into all of the
different realities there is a massive
information overload happening there's a
massive gluttony happening on earth
there's massive amounts of lies
happening we have the greatest tool
possible right now this information this
ability to disseminate information 8
billion people at the same time
and we're taking it for granted by
propagating so many lies in the most
greedy and corrupt ways truth is
paramount there's more split mind
schizophrenic people coming because of
the amount of lies there the reality is
being manipulated their reality is
becoming distorted and these some
conspiracies are actually correct and I
think it's really important to show here
that you know Alex Jones interestingly
enough actually had an IFB on and you
can see it here in this image that you
know who is Alex Jones talking to with
that IFB it's fascinating to even think
about that and it's really important for
us to get more of these Copernican
thoughts out there who is saying the
truth when 99.9 plus percent of people
are signing up for some sort of a
falsehood and so how do we get those
voiced out to more people around the
world so again in summary this is a
breakaway civilization this this is a
nest this is a yoke right these two
words breakaway civilization is gonna be
a bifurcation are we all gonna go
together how are we gonna give people
their opportunity to pick and choose
what they want to do we have yet to
realize our full divinity our full self
work as individuals and as a collective
our full communion with what this divine
reality even is how do you want this to
all evolve out have these stop provoking
conversations to other people get each
other thinking get each other building
get each other creating get away from
the parasites that are trying to control
you and be an independent thinker we are
an independent media company simulation
I'm Alan sake on you can find all of our
links below support the local artists
and entrepreneurs that you believe in
that you want to change the world
support them support us go and build the
future everyone manifest your destiny
into the world keep having these stop
provoking conversations let's get there
together I love you so much thanks for
tuning in give us your thoughts in the
comments below
much love peace